Thomas Middleditch is starring in a new
movie but this is no Silicon Valley
think about having sex with John
fortunately this dialogue doesn't even
matter Middleditch is having his face
and voice copied so that an artificial
intelligence named Benjamin that's it
right there on the laptop can stitch
them into a new film using face swapping
in vocal synthesis technology Benjamin
is a is a program that maniac over there
designed that's Ross Goodwin a
technologist at Google and a
self-described gonzo data scientist
Goodwin worked with director oscar sharp
Middleditch and benjamin on their first
AI film son spring which was licensed by
wired sister site Ars Technica
in 2016 son spring was made for a 48
hour sci-fi film challenge the team fed
Benjamin thousands of science fiction
film scripts and then had it write a new
one in future with mass unemployment
young people are forced to sell but you
should see the boy shut up the idea was
to see if the machine could write a
screenplay that the filmmakers could
work with Benjamin is a machine but
Benjamin is also a story about machines
is a story about how machines and
creativity can play together and what we
can learn from that a big honest idea
the AI comes up with the script I have
to go to the skull and it is our duty to
execute them as if the AI was Scorsese
some lines in there we were like what
meat does
what does Benjamin mean by this and
after breaking it down the best you can
do is interpret it because you can't ask
him that's right
no it's kind of fun just like really
playing it with like the most earnest
intent of some of the bizarre lines what
are you doing I don't want to be honest
with you you don't have to be a doctor
I'm sure I don't know what you're
talking about I'm gonna see you two what
do you mean after Sun Spring sharp good
one and Benjamin teamed up again with
wait for it in me David David Hasselhoff
activate Hoffman dangerous world of a
man who does not exist
for this second film the human
filmmakers tried to take a more
collaborative approach with the AI I
don't like to think that I'm just making
movies necessarily my whole thing has
always been what haven't we done yet
what can we try and the nice thing about
cinema is there's still lots of room to
try things and so for this year's 48
hour film festival they greenlit
Benjamin to become a full tour this year
we're having the Machine actually create
the movie visually as well as writing
the screenplay every decision is is the
computer's decision and the movie
therefore is directed by written and
directed by Benjamin that's my middle
ditch and the other actors are rambling
and grimacing so that Benjamin can start
building performances from their faces
and voices Benjamin constructed its new
movie using scenes from public domain
films like this test scene from Night of
the Living Dead at the moment we not in
the place where we can say you know it
writes there is a truck driving over the
horizon and it we can just come drew up
an image of a truck I'm a pretty girl
you know so instead what we thought we'd
do is let it from its screenplay
select shots from public domain films
and then using whichever shots that it's
picked drop these actors and these lines
of dialogue into that movie then at the
start of the 48 hour mark the team armed
Benjamin with the actors recordings the
scripts and the public domain films to
begin creating new scenes that would be
edited into a final movie
if this fails in experiment I'll be
employable for the rest of time and if
it doesn't fail and in fact works then
you know I may not be employable as an
actor but at least I will have been
there at the moment when we realized we
were going to be replaced by computers
even if the film is in a narrative
success the creators say it holds a
mirror up to the technologies that are
increasingly blurring the line between
truth and fictions both in the movies
and in real life that's so Benjamin to
help family r researchers digitally
produced a lip sync
speech by former President Barack Obama
and the infrastructure that creates good
new jobs and users of so-called deep
fake technology put the faces of
celebrities on the bodies of porn actors
we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point it's become
enough of an issue so director Jordan
Peele made this PSA in April of this
year this is a dangerous time a lot of
times in movies you can't tell but now
you're watching news footage or
interviews and you just can't tell if
it's real or not it's unsettling
unsettling maybe but the filmmakers
might say that's the whole idea behind
the project putting it in something
that's more playful and entertaining is
going to get a wider reach for that it's
gonna help more people understand that
this stuff can be done without needing
armies of CG experts anymore good
artists borrow great artists steal so
perhaps Benjamin will prove to be the
greatest of us all or not just tell me
where you're going in the end the script
was classic Benjamin I will be able to
rescue non sequiturs and all I am aware
of that what about the doctor you can't
do that and because of processing time
only first drafts of the face swaps
we're ready by deadline 16 shows perhaps
the best day swapping but she has to be
cut to meet the contest requirements for
life that's enough this is incredible
still the new film which is called zone
out has its moments you don't know where
this is going and it gives us a look at
what happens when you unleash an AI
on a creative project even this musical
score was generated by an AI you can
judge for yourself the director's cut
including the deleted scene is up now on
wired sister site Ars Technica how do
you know what happens to that guy I'm
doing it for you are you sure you need a
problem